and it looks so pretty with my tree I
love how this turned
out defend against a rapid spread of
micoplasma pneumonia AKA white lung
disease using black resins cogit packed
with immune boosting properties cogit
has been scientifically proven to
promote respiratory Health aiding in
oxygen absorption while also making the
body infection resistant strengthen your
family's immune system ahead of the
outbreak this winter don't forget to use
my discount code Ali dawa for 15% off
enjoy brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in so I
was uh scrolling on Instagram and I came
across a U video that was shared by one
of the Instagram pages that I follow and
I looked at it and I thought to myself I
don't know I don't know like I mean you
have double Minds about it it's like is
it a coincidence after the whole Zara
thing that we saw and what they did and
the person who did done the whole Zara
campaign the what that they doing the ad
campaign Etc had link Zionism so that
you can say it's more protable but when
it came to this Kim Kardashian Christmas
and she decides to wrap her gifts in
some kind of a cloth that resembles and
she's got a knot that resembles a
individual who's died well specifically
the H situation that's happening in
Palestine where over 27,000 people have
been massacred it's a gen genocide
that's happening so let's watch the
video for ourself and tell me what you
guys make of it inshah all right guys I
wanted to show you my wrapping this year
um I'm putting some presents in front of
the tree and I just want to show you
guys that I used skims cotton fabric for
my wrapping this year and um it's all
I'm going to reuse it and when everyone
opens it I'm going to take the fabric
and reuse it on stuff that I make for my
family so I thought it was a really fun
cool way to just have something that you
can use over and over again and I just
love the fabric and how it looks and it
looks so pretty with my tree I love how
this turned
out so guys you saw that for yourself I
was speaking to mus I thought to myself
is it a stretch I leave it to your
imagination I leave it to your mind but
is it a coincidence even if we say you
know what Kim kardashan had nothing to
do with it I believe there are people
higher ups right at the top who are
playing some kind of a game some kind of
calls are been shot maybe these things
are been told to them to do and they're
they're just like you know they just
following orders but maybe there's a
bigger game that's being played at the
top because is it a coincidence with the
H Zara thing what's going on in
Palestine and now that she decides to
wrap her Christmas gifts with a cloth
why would you do it why would you wrap
it with a cloth I don't understand why
why at this time why at any time if
anyone has an atom thought process would
know what's going on in Palestine and
I'm not saying she is pro is nothing for
that matter but at this moment of time
to wrap it in a way where it resembles
anyone that looks like will be like hold
on a second what bro what are you
talking about man you know there's
trigger points in the brain which is
like okay that's familiar with the
shrouds so I don't know I'm not going to
make accusations all I'm going to do is
is she mocking the Palestinians is she
not there's no evidence for it but it's
just bizarre and weird yes and it's just
a bit weird there's there's bit a weird
feeling to it that she decides to wrap
it up and not only that show people and
then she she also gives a link on a
story um and I don't recommend anybody
to go to the page I had to go to just
verify and be like is this from her I
don't recommend any brother to ever go
there in their lifetime everever but
yeah so I when there was a link she was
talking about gift WS I didn't really
understand it there was some pictures
some of the gift wraps were in just
simple normal gift wraps and the other
one was in a cloth so to me like I said
to you before brothers and sisters there
are people in the world who are calling
these shots and it reminds me of an ay
in the Quran in Bak where Allah subh is
having a discussion well kind of
dialogue with the angels and the angels
do as they are told but they ask Allah
oh Allah why do you like create a
creation that's going to cause Bloodshed
on the earth and Allah says I know what
you do not know so there are people who
are corrupt individuals who are causing
fit on the land and Allah says in the
Quran even same Surah that if you was to
ask them you know stop causing
corruption they will say rather we are
peace peacemakers and you can see that
Shayan and his allies and Satanism I
genuinely believe there are people
higher up who are playing games be it's
subconscious things be it's for example
when you're watching a movie and you see
this weird thing you know a triangle eye
where are these things steming from why
is a reoccurring pattern I genuinely
believe about it's again it's it's it
can be a conspiracy but I'll leave it to
your imagination brother sister
inshallah I'm not asking anyone to go
and give her hate for that matter but
what I'm just doing is it's a bit weird
and I'll leave that to your imagination
till next time brother sisters
um